we forget about something that I really
love the label of this we forget about
our emotional immune system which is
this idea that when we're in a difficult
situation we naturally bring to bear a
number of internal and external um
coping resources so we might bring our
sense of humor in to deal with it we
might know you know you know call a
friend kind of thing and those coping
resources which is part of our sort of
emotional immune response if you like
help bring down the intensity and the
duration of those emotional experiences
that we might have when we're struggling
with the task but we forget about our
emotional immune system because we don't
have the context we sort of seeing a
sliver of time with this task and we
forget about all the contextual elements
around it that are going to be there to
actually support us and make it actually
not anywhere near half as bad as what
we're imagining it to
[Music]
be